okay our our next speaker is an author
conservative and founder of the website
Atlas
shrugs and you you probably will
recognize her when she comes up here she
gave a seminar this morning that was
quite fiery and enjoyable concerning the
threat of radical Islam and matter of
fact we had an organization call for us
to uh ask her not to
speak well forget about
that and let me let me explain
[Applause]
why let me let me explain why we we just
don't have a care in the
world and I have something in my eye
it's an I don't care
hair please welcome Pamela Geller
I am so pleased to be here I want to
thank you I want to thank the Tennessee
tea party Coalition I want to thank
Vince and Anthony I want to thank all of
you for being so courageous it may not
seem that you are but let me tell you
something
when the unindicted
co-conspirator Muslim Brotherhood front
Hamas to kale
demanded that Franklin Graham be banned
from National Prayer day at the
Pentagon the greatest military
superpower in the world caved to the
Terra tide
care boo
when unindicted co-conspirator Hamas
front Muslim Brotherhood proxy care
demanded that Robert Spencer be banned
from the American Library Association
the library The Gatekeepers of human
thought he was
banned so I want to just say something
that very
important this is a free speech issue
and Care characterizes defense of free
speech freedom of conscience equal
rights for women as hate speech well
then I guess I'm a hater what I really
am is not an anti-islam speaker I am a
pro- freedom
speaker I love that and and for southern
boys and girls to welcome a New Yorker
like me where I get kicked around the
corner in that blue State I can't tell
you how encouraged I am because freedom
of
speech must be protected first and
foremost and not just the good
ideas but all ideas all content because
then who decides who decides what's a
good idea
Obama Care the organization of Islamic
conference
without freedom of speech free men will
have no choice they will have no
alternative but to to resort to violence
and we must use every tool in our
Arsenal before anything like that could
possibly happen and we are under attack
you're here in this room and this room
is a beautiful room and what you don't
see is that this is a battlefield and
today you were victorious because care
wants to do at the very least smear me
again and smear you with that racist
bigot label to marginalize you to make
people that like myself that speak to
Islamic supremacism they want to R make
us radioactive and toxic so that nobody
will hear us speak and that is a
restriction of free speech and what I
the message that I bring to you today
first is to learn everything because
this country is under attack and when
you say what do you mean um Sharia law
and someone said to you what is Sharia
law Sharia law is Islamic law and Islam
uh regards Sharia law to be above all
laws constitutional laws our
Constitution and Sharia law covers all
areas of life everything from hygiene
and dietary laws from religion to your
finances to dress codes to family to
social life everything
and I'm sure that you're not aware that
a week after Obama nationalized the
banks the US Treasury was giving
seminars in Sharia Finance now what's
wrong with Sharia Finance well first of
all we know that 10% of it goes to sakat
so you're financing Terror second of all
all Investments must be Halal meaning no
adult entertainment no alcohol no
cigarettes no pork well calling me
stupid but those are whole American
sectors those are huge business sectors
in America do do you want to finance
that do you want to finance Terror I
mean why would we be supporting Sharia
Finance why would the federal government
be giving seminars in Sharia Finance why
is Syracuse University giving seminars
in Sharia law it is foreign law there
must be a ban on Sharia now you could
say oh that's you know that's not a
problem it is a problem because in many
ways we are enforcing Sharia law a soft
Sharia the way the media will not speak
to Jihad the way the media will not
speak about Islam in any way is a is a
form of sharia law because it's slander
in Islam it's the um insulting of Islam
the defamation of Islam and we see it
all the time we see it when Comedy
Central bleeps out the word Muhammad we
see it when Comedy Central doesn't want
to run the little Huggy bit of
Muhammad this is Sharia law when the go
when the mayor of New York City says
that the Time Square bomber is somebody
who's pissed off at Obamacare that's
Sharia law when the media says that they
think it's some white
guy as but if they said they thought it
was a middle eastern guy and it was a
white guy liberal heads would be
exploding it is this impers perceptable
change in your lives that you don't even
see and it's happening Across America
the mking of the workplace the
introducing of prayer times that
non-muslims have to follow because their
workday is lengthened it's the it's it's
it's installing Muslim footbaths in
universities and in airports your tax
your Infidel taxpayer dollars at
work it's in public schools where they
introdu when where little Muslim
children want to pray so they they set
aside a prayer
room and now you've introduced uh uh
Muslim prayer into the school system
would you ever get that for a Christian
Child ever not in your wildest dreams
you have an you have an islamophilia
president who has created a department
at the state department for the Outreach
to the um the the uh Muslim Global
Community Where is the Outreach to the
non-muslim world where is the recompense
for
911 I live in New York City and I'm
leading in the an opposition a rally on
June 6th D-Day and the symbolism should
not be lost on you to oppose the 911
Mega mosque at Ground Zero
now I want to talk about the 911 megga
mque for a minute because it's very
important that you understand symbolism
in Islamic history everything is
symbolic the name of the initiative the
Cordoba initiative was when you know the
Islamic conquest of
Spain uh the building itself if you've
seen the rendering looks like a Trade
Center the World Trade
Center it's scheduled to open on
September 11th
and they talk in such an insulting I'm
insulted as a non-muslim I'm offended
you know can I be offended or it's only
one way street I'm offended that they
want to build a shrine to the very
ideology that inspired those those
attacks on those
Towers I believe it should be a mosque
bre Zone but even if it weren't why not
build a center dedicated to the hundreds
of millions of non-muslims and Muslims
that have died in a millennium over a
millennium of jihad Wars land
Appropriations cultural Annihilation and
enslavements or at the very least to the
911 victims or as the Imam rou said
those harmed by 911 harmed by 911 you
know the Prime Minister of Turkey said
the mosques are our fortresses and the
minettes are our bayonets now this is a
moderate Muslim country the Prime
Minister of Turkey also said to Obama
there is no extreme Islam there is no
moderate Islam Islam is Islam and the
Taliban who I don't know if you're aware
of it is Obama's you know he wants he
wants to partner with the Taliban now
what's he going to partner in poisoning
the girls schools in Afghanistan what's
he going to partner with the Taliban for
said there is no extreme Islam it's an
insult it is Islam and I think that this
campaign of disinformation to the
American people is is the most damaging
and the biggest threat we face today
because it's like that analogy where you
know if you throw a frog into boiling
water it jumps right out but if you put
a frog in tepid water and you slow boil
it it boils to death and I'm telling you
we're boiling to
death the the soft
Sharia is just as dangerous if not more
so than the violent Jihad now we know
the violent Jihad we see it in the
Christmas balls bomber we see it in the
Fort Hood Jihadi and what's even more
troubling is if you saw the Pentagon
report from the Fort Hood Jihad that
first of all I have to tell you that
when I do presentations many times I use
used the PowerPoint presentation that
major Hassan the Jihadi made on Grand
rounds he had a PowerPoint presentation
that boiled Jihad down to its essential
oils and I think when he was when he
presented that at Grand Ms he was coming
out as a
Jihadi he gave away Kur qurans on the
day of his Jihad he his little business
card said soldier of Allah when the
Pentagon did their review of that Jihad
they never once mentioned Islam they
they never me mentioned uh Jihad they
would not discuss religious
motivation how are you going to fight an
enemy that you are afraid to
name you have so so the
Pentagon the Pentagon has so subdued
itself which is what Islam tells the
cfer that's us to do and you have on all
fronts you are being assaulted you being
assaulted on the academic front the
universities have become hostile places
for for for Jewish uh students um for
any Israel any pro-israel action at all
uh kids get beat up the uh Middle
Eastern studies departments are hot beds
of jihad they're using they're using
texts with Rewritten histories you have
a litigation Jihad against people like
me who speak they sue us they sue us
they don't expect to win
they expect to bankrupt us they expect
to shut us up with litigation I mean we
passed a law in New York Rachel's law
and I know that you did it here in
Tennessee too okay uh you did it in
Tennessee too people that suited it's
liable it's it's liable tourism what I'm
saying to you is that you must become
aware of the advancing Jihad in this
Society you must look around your
schools your towns you must look at your
children's textbook you must see what
they're being told you must fight you
must get on school boards you must get
in precincts you must fight the advance
of Islam there is
an there is an economic Jihad there is a
cultural Jihad you'll see the cfia is it
like the cfia is like a h fashionista
scarf now it's a
swasa the catha is a war scarf of jihad
the children in Iran many they're
commanded to wear it to to to to show
solidarity with their their Muslim
Brothers in
Gaza we are at War we are at War and I
tell you that the the information battle
space the war of ideas is where the real
war is fought and where the subsequent
blood and bullets and bombs are result
of that war and I ask you to be a
soldier for freedom and you can't sit
back anymore those days are over we've
used up the greatest generations card
it's over the bill is due and you know
you're at the cash
register thank you very much for having
me God bless you God bless America
[Applause]